hello and a warm welcome and joining us
for the president's design awards
creating a better world by design series
using lists to create more impact
my name is juliana yao and i'll be your
mc for today
the president's design award or pda for
short is singapore's highest accolade
for designers and designs across all
disciplines
organized by the design singapore
council and the urban redevelopment
authority this is the 13th cycle of the
award
the last crop of 11 pda 2020 recipients
were awarded on 30th of june 2021.
to find out more about these recipients
do visit the travelling exhibition which
is currently at its last week at the
singapore university of technology and
design campus center level 2 which is
happening until the 31st of march 2022
the next call for entries for pda 2023
will be launching in september this year
so please do follow design singapore
council on instagram for exciting
updates
i do also want to run through a couple
of house rules just to keep today's
session running as smoothly as possible
firstly please be informed that this
webinar will be recorded and that your
microphones will be muted throughout the
session
however you are most welcome to submit
questions through the zoom q a function
and the speakers will be addressing them
during our q and a segment
should you encounter any technical
issues please ping our technical team
through the zoom chat function
for boa and sia members joining us today
there will be two cpd points credited
for this webinar so please do stay until
the end of the webinar to fill in the
survey form with your respective details
to qualify for the cpd points
in today's session we'll hear from three
of our pda 2020 recipients on projects
that have used less materials costs and
even labor to create a positive impact
on the economy
community society quality of life and
the environment
so how can designers address the
interest and demand for positive impact
while keeping in mind that our resources
are limited and adopt a regenerative
design approach
we hope to tackle this big question with
our panel of speakers today
so it is now my pleasure to introduce
the pda 2020 recipients on our panel
firstly we have professor carlos bannon
director and co-founder of the
architectural intelligence research lab
or air lab at the singapore university
of technology and design
second we have architect paul chi
director at wahawa architects
and last but not least we have mr prasun
kumar co-founder of billion bricks
our moderator for today would be dr jose
rezai director of web structures
dr rezai is the pda 2020 jury vice chair
of the design panel and also the pda
2016 designer of the year recipient he
is joining us from canada this afternoon
and would like to especially thank dr
razan for joining us at such a late hour
at night
now before we begin the session we will
get to know a little bit more about you
so tell us a little bit more about your
background and which fields you are
currently working or perhaps studying in
via the poll that will be launching on
your screen you can choose more than one
option if that applies to you so you
should be able to see a couple of these
options popping up on your screen at
this point of time we have architecture
which i imagine most of you would be
from but perhaps you are also from
product and industrial design
maybe it's ui ux design visual
communications and advertising interior
design maybe
other design disciplines or perhaps
you're not even
in a design discipline but you're keen
to perhaps make a career switch or to
find out more
about some of these sustainable
practices today so really here to find
out a little bit more about our audience
so perhaps some of the questions uh can
be catered to that in the q and a
session later on as well so just taking
a look at the results
and as expected
we have most of our audience here today
92 of you in fact from the architecture
field so certainly you guys are here to
find out more about how you can you know
incorporate some of these
learnings into what you do on a daily we
do see one percent in product and
industrial design two percent of you a a
very very small percentage probably just
one or two of you in the other design
discipline so very interesting to know
and that little two percent of you in
non-design disciplines so just great to
know where our audience is from today a
little bit more about you but now we're
going to drive straight into the sharing
by our speakers
so without further ado let us welcome
our very first speaker for today
professor carlos bannon
as director and co-founder of the
architectural intelligence research lab
at sutd
carlos leads the multi-disciplinary
research laboratory focusing on
architecture science arts digital design
and manufacturing they combine new
technologies and digital manufacturing
to create efficient light and versatile
products that aim to increase
sustainability and reduce wing stage in
construction
his team received the pda 2020 design of
the year for the air mesh pavilion the
first in the wall to be made out of 3d
printed stainless steel components so
over to you carlos
carlos i'll have you unmute your mic i
think you might be on mute
okay thank you very much juliana and the
whole presidential award team for
arranging this fantastic event we're
excited to be speaking here uh and to
see everyone joining us
so um yeah
i would like to talk about like the you
know some of the
concerts that i've worked in uh recently
um applied to the to the design that i
just mentioned here the image pavilion
but some others as well that i will
present today
so i'm gonna try to
go to my slides still cannot see the
slides in screen
are they on
i only can see my slide right now
okay
carlos perhaps you can try clicking on
the next slide your cochlear is on yeah
i'm trying
sorry gonna move slides now
it doesn't react
okay finally yeah sorry
okay so moving on sorry about that um so
um well um starting with these slides to
portray the kind of the big drawing that
we have in construction industry that we
create more than 20 million tons of
construction waste every year
so
one of the things that we do in our lab
is to
look for new technologies that can lower
the energy that we use in production and
also to create
zero waste uh products right so we try
to address stability from different
sites 3d printing is one of them we
really believe strongly on this
technology and also we look at create
the creation of more sustainable spaces
using less resources and materials by
placing it where actually is needed
so
we started looking at the topology of
the space frames actually it's a very
old topology we have seen structures
everywhere in the cities like sports
halls uh many places in the world like
they have this technology everywhere
creates these regular grids uh allows
for a certain level of flexibility
certain degree of it and this is the
standard system basically you have a
node and then you have bars connecting
towards the nodes in standardized angles
so we have this question uh this is a
kind of a well proven technology that
really works over time but uh it allows
for a certain degree of flexibility but
not a lot can we challenge that
construction technology so that we can
create more efficient structures
so with that vision in mind we'll look
at what actually exists in the market
and uh and what could be the vision of
the future of those structures allows
for free form
geometric continuity and extreme
slenderness by spreading the load in
more slender components
so looking at nature
as a source of inspiration like looking
at neural networks and its hyper
redundancy and interconnectivity we
develop a concept whereby
the nodes were generated by the forces
that runs through the system
so we 3d print a
spoke component that can integrate those
components that actually are standard
profiles
so we can create complex networks
and then is when digital design takes
place to address that complexity now we
have the aid of tools right tools are
not the answer but it's a mean truly
achieve certain goals in this case to
reduce the material to the minimum and
to achieve maximum free form in our
designs so you can see here from the top
left the bottom right the sequence that
we use to generate the nodes from the
force and the vectors we create the
complex nodes for each of the points
where actually we place the material and
the good thing here is that thanks to 3d
printing we
can generally decide where not to place
the material which is more important
than where to place it because we can
decide where not are we putting material
at the almost like a you know scale of
the millimeter
so that allows us to to really reduce
the weight so you can see one of the
notes that we developed for the air mesh
project so it's i would say it's mostly
made of air the volume actually you can
see is 90 air
so we develop further the connection
system so develop the interface between
the standard components and the 3d
printed parts so
we calculate the structure with finite
element analysis and we assign a section
to the bars that actually defines the
shape of the nodes
so what you can see here is one of these
nodes right this complex geometries uh
real time generated with our script so
we can create a bespoke connection for
each of the parts of the structure that
can integrate um the different bars with
different profiles in the structure
creating a network this complex
so we can start with just three
components and we can actually add more
as needed so the more we add actually
the more we can spread the load into
thinner components linear parts that
allows for more flexibility and to
spread the load more efficiently through
the system so instead of using system of
beams and columns we're using this
spatial network that addresses
structures in a way more efficient way
so we wanted to achieve that geometric
freedom and that's why we developed the
air mesh pavilion so the hermes pavilion
sits at the gardens by the bay
look at the views as the way to define
the geometry we have four points three
landmarks and the access point that
defines the geometry of the pavilion is
quite straightforward just the four
vectors define the shape you can see
here the section but below you can see
the
configuration the special configuration
actually is a two layer you create a
volume so that the structure is more
efficient
it's made out of tetrahedrons
so the most basic structures especially
structure that we have the transitions
are deformed and adapt to create any
shape that's done with our script so we
can discretize any geometry into the
transitions we can actually build
efficiently based on the structures that
are running through the members
those nodes these 54 nodes are
digitally created with our script so
those nodes are of different shapes
different proportions different weights
and we use 3d printing to fabricate them
this one actual node
and the interface and connection between
the bar and the node can be performed in
only that
so it reduces the time that it takes to
build these structures on a structure
like this about 35 square meter took
only two days with a team of researchers
were actually not a construction company
was basically us putting the bars and
the boards together
so um that is a huge improvement because
we can develop and fabricate and
assemble a high performance structure in
minutes
using just a hex key to connect and this
is the materiality of the pavilion we
have created this space that seals in
gardens by the bay for the next few
months you can actually visit there
close to the bay front pavilion it's
just a space where you can sit down you
can chill you can look at the views you
can experience lightness
and uh and at night you have this very
uh nice light effects thanks to led is
strategically placed in the sides
to create different nuances next to the
um to the to the lake at the gardens by
the bay
so moving on uh we also want to make
more impact using reduced resources so
we don't care about the scale or
materials or production we can tackle it
throughout them so we look at the way to
implement the system also in furniture
scale so how to design a table that can
transfer the loads into just three
minute points like smaller than a i
don't know
50 cents coin so can we transfer this
200 kg into three points so we use the
element system to prove it right
those bars extremely thin like six
millimeter diameter and the precision is
extreme how they connect seamlessly
between nords of nodes and bars how can
create a complex network throughout them
you can see here the
final result how the table can withstand
the load service load of a table and
only touching in very very little
surface
so we also explored that with bamboo how
to redefine traditional construction
using 3d printing to reduce the
utilization utilization of resources but
also embrace
the use of
bamboo this is actually a carbon sink uh
and definitely can um
you know
help us achieve like sustainable designs
um and the way that we did it this time
was to
scan using 2d scanners the shape of the
bamboo and to 3d print a connector that
fits exactly to the shape of each of the
bamboo poles because they're irregular
so with that system we can create a
bespoke component in minutes and we can
interface the bamboo in a quite novel
way allow us to create canopies or even
disaster relief structures that can be
deployed in just hours
we have used the same technology as well
for farming systems to create a 100
biodegradable system
and a frame system that can instead of
the nodes now we have the trout so we
can grow plants there and it's adapted
to any geometry we have tested that with
our industry partner cdl and we are
actually scaling up to to a larger
larger
scale really soon
and lastly we only have 10 minutes i
want to conclude this break with just
small art pieces that we finished
recently that title the problem of waste
that is a huge problem and now we're
getting more and more um requests from
industry on how to address waste um in
designs so now the briefs that we get as
designers are very different than we had
before before you they know what you
want to do
as a as a industry partner in this case
it's like well we have a lot of waste
and then you guys as designers you
should try to do something with it right
so so we we came up with this design for
chanel
that i'm presenting here right now
[Music]
transport reconnection of these
particular models using
and also creating a complex interface
between the bottles and parts
[Music]
it is very important to read some words
about this problem
[Music]
how can we stand in life of the process
with his heart
[Music]
to the face of its kind
we are looking at implemented into
chanel stores the coming months
[Music]
thank you
thank you for sharing carlos and our
next speaker is architect paul chi
director at wahawa architects
she leads the project teams through
design execution and implementation of
innovative and award-winning private and
public projects
over the last decade waha has been
researching and innovating new
architectural and urban solutions to
tackle the challenges of climate change
rapid loss of biodiversity population
growth and urbanization
her team received the pda 2020 design of
the year for kampung admiralty a
groundbreaking project that was a
successful integration of a complex
socially driven breathe while
maintaining a human-centric approach so
paul over to you please
hi thank you everyone um
am i loud and clear
yes okay thank you
um
good afternoon everyone um
i'm going to uh
uh
introduce uh campo emeriti this project
and the design ideas behind it
we were able to work on this project
with multiple government agencies
to come up with a new prototype to bring
the kampung spirit which celebrates
healthy communal living into the urban
setting of the 21st century this
prototype demonstrate an innovative
mixed use that has potential to be
adaptable and multiplied
and it shows how buildings can be urban
infrastructure and ecosystem that
improves the quality of greenery
community space and biodiversity in
cities
um
the the site is located next to the
train station um a prime location in
terms of real estate value the building
and this public space are connected to
this public transport network and and
actually have become a natural urban
focal point
um the site is in is highlighted in raid
it's in a mature housing estate in
singapore
and uh which conventionally comprise of
residential blocks and a town center
with standalone amenities
now the site is
next to the mrt station highlighted in
blue and is also accessible by major
arterial roads
multiple existing pedestrians and
cycling routes cuts through it towards
the train station and the park
connectors
here the site is chosen for its
strategic location in a mature town so
in the next few slides i'll take you
through a series of design diagrams to
explain the layering of the different
programs the footprint of the site is
about 9 000 square meter in area
and the project brief has four key
components commercial medical center
community programs and public housing
for the elderly so these are facilities
run by different government agencies and
co-locating them on this
the challenge we face um
is how to accommodate all the facilities
in this very small site
which is slightly less than one hectare
and we propose vertically uh stacking uh
the map which means many of the
facilities could not be be located on
the ground floor
and the challenge is to have a design
that elevate the concerns of the
agencies and overcome the challenge of
the of the site constraint
the first key move was to put the
supermarket retail shops
and food center on the ground layer by
compacting the commercial footprint over
two floors we free the ground floor for
a tropical plaza and the next move was
to overlay the large footprint of the
medical center over the plaza this
provides shape and shelter for the plaza
which is crucial for its usability in
the tropics
by lifting the medical center to the mid
layer all weather activities can now
take place in a fully public porous and
pedestrianized plaza below the high
volume also allows natural daylight and
breezes through ensuring a high degree
of thermal comfort for people
the next key move was to overlay the
community users of a quieter nature such
as the child care eldercare and public
housing to the upper layer and over this
a new elevated ground level was created
by introducing a community sky park
where young and old can come together
this community sky park with his gardens
and urban farms adopt a topographical
architectural language of terraces and
hills
and at the foothill
of the community sky park we introduced
the apartment blocks of the public
housing for elderly and the hills
effectively shielded the apartments from
the train noise which is behind the
building
so instead of a standalone program it is
now a layered integrated urban village
the free ground level and new elevated
ground level generates more horizontal
surfaces for landscape and people as a
result
let's take a closer look at how we
layered the program vertically through a
section of the building complex
here are two basements
for car parking which is below ground
and
the lower layer of this building
comprises two floors the ground floor is
a porous
tropical
plaza that brings the community together
the ground is designed to prioritize
pedestrian circulation through a
building to the train station
the plaza is a bright and breezy double
volume space that serves as a community
living room it is activated by shops and
a food center at the upper layer
and the oculus in the center opens up to
light air and views of the community sky
park above
the plaza now is a popular social space
and provides daily conveniences to
residents
moving up to the mid layer we spread the
medical center over two floors the
footprint of the medical center covers
almost the entire site
and all the internal waiting and
circulation areas are organized around a
center garden courtyard
architecturally the medical center is
like an umbrella sheltering uh the plaza
below and it's also acting as a
supporting floor for the landscape above
this view of the medical center
we've all experienced hospitals
especially waiting areas has quite
sometimes sterile uncomfortable places
uh but here the courtyard brings natural
daylight and green into the medical
center leveraging on the bar feeling
effect that nature has on humans the
central rain garden helps to promote a
sense of healing and well-being
so this waiting area with daylight from
the garden courtyard
patient area such as the rehab gym
and training rooms all look into gardens
the upper layer of the building
comprises quieter more private community
facilities the six-story floor plan is
where the community sky park forms the
new elevated ground level for child care
elder care and community gardens and
playgrounds
the apartment
windows actually opens to view of the
community sky park
and child care and elder care are side
by side
at this level and also adjacent to
landscape outdoors so this adjacency or
program actually brings the young and
all together
encouraging intergenerational bonding so
they share the playground and outdoor
exercise
station
and
you know uh while doing that they could
socialize with each other and also at
the same time take care of urban
community farm so the idea of locating
the farm on the rooftop encourages the
elderly to be active
of course we have lifts and ramps that
are provided to help person using
wheelchairs
this is the public housing block
is eight units per floor and the units
are modular and designed with
barrier-free access
they arrange in pairs with buddy nooks
at shared entrances for neighbours to to
sit chat together and make friends
this is a view of the apartment blocks
um sort of growing out of the park and
surrounded by large landscape
the body noobs are benches designed to
encourage interaction at shared
entrances for each pair of apartments so
main doors are usually kept open for
ventilation uh in this case it also
helps neighbors to keep watch over each
other
for passive environmental strategies um
we use it to to achieve green
performance for the building so all the
public spaces and apartments are
designed for natural ventilation and
hence not reliant on air conditioning
and the precast facade
will create a deep sun shade and
also colorful to add visual orientation
and interest all the roof surfaces are
landscape and is good for reducing
thermal load
embracing landscape brings benefit of
being able to look out to greenery and
being close to nature
in compound emerity we we have a
planting palette that encourages
biodiversity
the result is a good healthy number of
species of insects birds and fruit beds
now
with
point eye hectares
footprint we actually has almost 50 over
projected species which is captured in
our post occupancy biodiversity survey
so the survey that we did was also
extended to a nearby
neighborhood park and we compared the
two uh the the park is almost uh the
same side footprint as well almost a a
hectare but actually it has less
projected species at 39 so it's 56
versus 39 so compared to
a conventional neighborhood park which
is
likely mostly like hard landscape and
with little variation in planting
palette the landscape in this building
uh performs far better as we make this
biodiversity comparison so imagine if we
have 10 of this more than 100 landscape
replacement buildings and when we make
connections between them it's performing
equivalent to a typical 10 hectare city
neighborhood park so this is the
potential
of the project as a prototype
the approach in kampong mlt
is multiplying and maximizing the
building system of greenery and
community spaces making the system
both useful and enjoyable so these are
calculations that we did of
what has been achieved in the building
which is 110
landscape replacement compared to site
area and 150 community spaces
this building is new since 2017 has been
and it's inclusive and and successful
and i'm happy to say that the government
also has made
some plans to develop similar prototypes
in other towns
okay with this thank you
thank you very much pearl for your
insightful sharing next we have mr
prasun kuma co-founder of billion bricks
prasun co-founded berlin bricks in 2012
as a non-profit that uses design and
technology to reimagine housing and to
solve the global housing crisis in a
completely new way so for the pda 2020
presumes team
received the design of the year award
for the itaenia green school a learning
ecosystem designed for the stateless
children whose parents work in the oil
palm plantations of saba so welcome
presume
hi everyone and thank you for having me
here today um i'm going to talk about
the project titania green school but
really end my presentation with kind of
a thought-provoking idea on the on the
theme today which is using less to
create more impact i really feel that
the the purpose of these convert these
conversations is really not to know so
much about the projects i think there's
enough material online that we can read
today but really to kind of go back with
some questions that can bring change in
the work that we do on a daily basis
uh so i i think uh um i'll probably
start with a little bit introduction i
mean billion bricks was founded uh
in 2013 uh as a non-profit but as of
2022 we've actually shifted to now being
a for-profit enterprise but with still a
similar vision of addressing the
housing challenge that the world is
facing uh the key principle behind
founding billion bricks was really to
um the idea that that often times when
we do buildings for the poor or when we
work for the community we are too much
driven by the idea of making the
buildings cheaper and that drives most
of the decision making and design kind
of takes the back seat but the idea is
really of giving equal opportunities
through design to as many people as
possible because we as designers do
believe in the fact that it adds to a
lot more layers of value for the people
so the project that i'm going to talk
about is is a project that deals with
students in malaysia
and there are actually about 50 000
children in malaysia which are
considered to be stateless what it means
is that they have no citizenship rights
for any country in the world so they
live in malaysia but their parents come
from countries such as philippines and
indonesia to work in oil plantations
when they're born in malaysia malaysia
doesn't recognize them as citizens and
philippines and indonesia also fail to
too as well so they live quite deep in
the plantations quite cut off from rest
of the
community uh and itania is the
organization that we partnered with
which runs uh schools very deep inside
uh these communities um uh to provide
education to them and what they do is
that they go in and find
say for example abandoned buildings or
some shopping centers which are again
very very obscure and they kind of take
some rooms in it in which they build
schools and they find local teachers and
teach them so this is kind of one of the
classroom that they had
so for us the key thing was that these
these children and students they've
really been deprived of all kind of
human rights that we can think of and
education is i think far beyond on their
radar as well i mean they're not even
recognized as a citizen in any part of
the world was to really provide a sense
of place
which belongs to them and it's a school
or a building which has really been
created for them and not something which
is adapted and been donated and stuff to
them as well so dignity and pride was
was a key criteria uh when we started
designing this building and that really
gave a lot of impetus on how we looked
at the landscape the building design and
various aspects of really setting the
building into that space as well the
other aspect was that uh the fact that
they are very resource constrained in
terms of the teaching aids like are we
our kids have access to textbooks and
computers and stuff they have very
limited access to resources but how can
we use the environment itself as a
teaching aid and how can we create
opportunities for teachers for students
for parents to kind of learn from that
environment rather than create
artificial means to teach them and i
think we were also very advantaged with
the kind of site we had with the amount
of foliage and water
and the proximity to a river that really
created that opportunity and even as
architects and consume the fact that 98
of us today here are architects was
really an exciting opportunity for us as
well to kind of maximize uh on the
opportunities that that came in
but it's important to recognize that
this is
in a part of malaysia which is in sabah
which is
a home to one of some of the largest uh
primary forests in the world and the
largest
sinks of carbon in the world as well and
they have been
being raised
at a massive pace and we all have some
responsibility towards it we use
uh materials
uh food products toothpastes
toothbrushes makeup materials which are
all made from these palm oil plantations
which are being done by removing all
these trees and we
we understand these things but we are
not able to reduce our footprint towards
it so this was a great recognition for
us as well the site was also like i said
very close to the river which in case of
this river in buford has a habit of
flooding every couple of years and the
floods are so high that i remember going
there for the site visit and we were
sitting in a restaurant and you could
actually see the water level
marks on the wall which were about two
meters above the ground level so it
really floods uh fairly deep inside and
we had to kind of manage it and we
didn't really have to learn anything
from there you could go around and look
at the houses that people have been
built and buildings they are generally
stilted up or if they find a higher
plane uh they kind of just put it on the
on the higher so there isn't really a
rocket science to building those things
right and we kind of adopted those
things to say uh can we create an
artificial hill or can we find systems
to prop up the building uh which are
both
recycled materials like you see which
are the containers here but also
as a system to to reduce the costs of
the building as well
so for us it was a clean site i mean
there were a couple of trees that we've
preserved on the site we took a part of
the uh
the the land itself and we created a
mound out of it which created one part
of the structure and we ensured that
that kind of stays
is to the height of a shipping container
and then we build a couple of very light
structure that you can see as um as
columns to float literally the building
on top of it we we had access to these
containers from a donor from from san
francisco so we got them shipped from a
port in malaysia uh and we the initial
idea for everyone was to use the
containers uh as a way to actually um uh
use these for housing the children but
we realized that it's very expensive and
very hot in these climates and actually
to do these kind of changes as well we
use very few materials this is the
entire material palette that you can see
that we use to build us the school um
and we really used aids which becomes a
fun way to for for children to start
interacting with the school the
orientation was really where they can
actually look into the um the
river on one side a very linear linear
linear school with corridor uh and rooms
on either side and then it could be
extended as the school's needs would
grow so this has about five uh
classrooms in it uh it was designed for
rainwater harvesting for solar panels so
entire energy is used by solar panels
there's rain water collection which
happens in the pond that we created and
the sewage is clean up onto the side as
well
[Music]
so i think the the interesting thing
about the school is really the fact that
the outside and inside as you can see
are really one right so and i remember
going there and speaking to teachers and
they said that times use the classrooms
as as the dance theaters but they use
the outside under the tree area as a
classroom as well so it's really a space
for people to make on their own but the
thought i want to leave you is really on
the on the title of today's
subject which is using less to create
more impact and if you just look at what
was used less in this current particular
project the construction cost was very
very low none of us that worked on the
project took any salaries the teachers
are paid a very minimal salary as well
and the materials were kind of recycled
and as you can see the material pallet
was very less used as well and therefore
the energy and the consumption of
resources in the building is very very
less on the more side the impact was
really that these stateless children
could get access to a school we could
introduce a new design type apology by
using these materials and we received a
lot of awards and publicity other than
the pda as well and you can see it
online as well right so the point really
is that in reality
this more impact is very small
in terms of the problem that we are
trying to address so here there are 50
000 children but all the school does it
serves 240 children so we may think that
the impact is very large that these
things are scalable but they hardly ever
scale
and in fact even the kids are proud of
it this is the picture of the school
that my kids go to uh i think if we
would have designed a similar building
we may not have received the awards but
probably those children would have still
loved it as much as possible so the
point i want to make is really that the
more impact side in such a scenario is
more about us
having a new design typology that we can
talk about get excited about get these
awards and publicity but the impact on
the crown is quite minimal and we have
to figure out how can we overcome this
and i think the way to overcome this
that using less
in reality creates less impact we have
less money we create less of these foods
for these children we have more less
money to pay ourselves we can't do so
much of work and we have less materials
we can again build less number of
schools so we really need to change our
thinking and do more to create more
impact
and not just talk about it but actually
take action
in doing these more things if you really
believe in more impact so thank you for
that and then i'm happy to answer
questions and looking for the discussion
with the rest of the panelists and
doctors
all right thank you very much recipients
for all your sharing and of course right
now we will be jumping into our
moderation session so i'm going to hand
the time over to our moderator dr jose
rezai for the q and a session
dr zai is an engineer a design visionary
and an educator he is the first and only
engineer to receive the pda designer of
the year as one of the initiators of the
concept of fusion engineering
he is passionate about the process of
advanced computational design and a
holistic approach to architecture and
structure and the environment
in addition to having been on the pda
design jury panel in 2018 and 2020 he is
the first practitioner in singapore to
have been invited to join the master
jury of the agar khan award for
architecture so let us welcome dr rizzai
and recipients
um
thank you thank you juliana for the for
the
for that introduction
and um thank you
carlos pal and
prasun
for
the beautiful presentation on three
truly deserving pda
winning designs the time is
just past
1am here in vancouver where i'm visiting
and you've managed to more than keep me
awake with those beautiful presentations
thank you for that in my experience
good presentations tend to receive two
diametrically opposing reactions from
the audience
they either leave us in awe
and therefore generate no questions
from our interactions with the audience
alternatively they motivate us to want
to know more with multiple questions and
enquiries
let's see what reactions we get from the
rather large audience we have
today
to start
our panel discussions
um you know for me in addition to all
the very interesting aspects of the
three projects that you all shared
what binds together the three rather
different projects is a sense of
enabling justice
justice through our projects
regardless of scale genre
and locations
all three projects in my opinion
propagate a sense of
um social justice and or environmental
justice
uh
both of which are so lacking in in the
in the world we live in today and some
of which we all to bearing degree are
responsible for for the propagation of
um
if you don't mind me um
do a bit of self-criticism of ourselves
as as designers engineers and and
architects
but to start a panel discussion i wonder
if any of you would like to briefly
talk about justice as a
design motivator or driver in your work
perhaps per would you would you like to
speak to this a little bit
um yes uh thank you dr rozelle
um
i think kampung emerald being uh
well it's uh it's a public building and
uh there is some social agenda
to it as well
um
i think when we
started looking at the project the
location
is um actually it is a
location of prime sd
and during the initial design process of
course because there are many agencies
co-locating that facility so it is a
question of what what other who are
going to get the the ground floor to use
which is again
uh of uh prime estate value as well um
but actually uh we created uh public
spaces
that connects um that that become
uh the heart of the community i mean
it's a space that
that is um
tropical it's it's um
people are able to to come and use it
they pass us through it they pass
through it to go to the train station
every day and there is activated by
you know by uh shops and all that so
um it's a very uh people-centric kind of
uh you know uh designing public spaces
bringing back public spaces
to to kind of central location you know
next to a train station
i i think in many parts of the world the
train station is actually a very uh uh
public space yeah and so this project
tries to give as much public space back
uh
to the community
yeah
that's my my thought yeah
beautiful thank you very much thank you
um
would you would you like to um to talk
to this to the topic of justice
environmental and social and i know your
work is highly
uh
cognizant of the of some of the
injustice that we that we have around us
yeah i mean firstly i should commend you
with starting with some self-criticism
on it i think we are all part of that
story right and
uh i i think that the key thing about
understanding a justice through design
from a social and environmental aspect
is just the fact that the
the opportunity that a designer has in
their hand is to create
um a world
through their work which has equality so
everyone has
an opportunity for equal access to
resources and therefore the
environmental damage or the distribution
of resources is reduced at the same time
we have the same opportunities to our
buildings but i think we all kind of
understand this idea we speak about it
and we can do them at project level
right we can do a go out a project like
per mention and then we can deliver it
on that particular project but i think
where these things can actually make a
difference is we can start stop looking
at them at a project level but really
imbibe them as values in everything that
we do in our companies and in our work
and with all the clients that we do
and i remember reading an article a
couple of weeks ago in the newspaper
which talked about the fact that one of
the companies in singapore is doing a
shopping mall in in dubai which is five
times the size of weaver city right so
when we do projects like that and we do
one project where we may be doing less
impact on the environment then the
negative impact of the other project
completely negates what we are doing in
here so do we have the ability to within
our framework do the right thing and
equalize it and make sure that the
design carries that forward not only at
a project level but at value level
yeah thank you so the the question of
the question scale is uh is one that um
that obviously matters whether we do we
do say in design or somebody else said
that size doesn't matter but scale does
and maybe science does matter in fact
when it comes to to addressing the
um the challenges that uh that we are we
are um all facing at the moment um the
um
there are a couple of questions from the
audience about the projects about the
presentations that you have made maybe i
just uh
try to raise them
um here
so one
address is addressed to pearl um
well it's sort of like a factual
question being asked um i think any uh
any particular issues to do with uh
issues on post completion
uh did you have any feedback from the
ability tampon project to share
um pros and cons of this concept
learn for future work
um
i'm not 100 if i fully understand the
question i wonder what is about the
partial partial completion or or is it
about feedback from the from the people
who live there i know you you shared
with us something about obviously you
know the biodiversity that exists in
tampon adversity as opposed to a similar
size park etcetera that is i suppose the
feedback um from our other friends and
other species that that they like
kampung admiralty a little bit more than
the than the other landscape park but do
you have any other feedback from people
who you who've lived there and how they
how they are enjoying the project
i think i've heard good feedback um
uh it's
i think the the elderly residents
who booked the flats and and finally
moved in uh they themselves were
surprised uh by
uh
by the
the
lay of programs in the building the the
kind of convenient access that they can
have
you know literally the healthcare
uh the supermarket you know that their
needs can be met at the doorstep because
they they for the i think this could be
the first
uh development that integrate uh elderly
public flats
into a project like this yeah so i think
this this integration yeah it draws a
lot of good feedback from from the
residents and um
it seems that as a result of that they
were very active i mean there are active
volunteers from them
uh in the urban farm in the same
building and also
volunteer at the elder care center in
the same building yeah
so i think i think that the integration
brings brings quite quite good uh a
lifestyle
to this uh elderly residents
great
carlos a question
on a theme
coming
on sustainability um
a little bit of an introduction on the
question by me obviously sustainability
has been the buzzword across various
industries and disciplines
at least since the 80s
when it was somewhat officially
described in the you know now very
famous bruntland report
he's been guiding a lot of what we do as
architects engineers and designers
and what we've done in the past 40 years
or so some believe now
that
it no longer responds to the challenges
we're facing
others go further and say that the whole
premise of sustainability was flawed
right from the beginning
that the notion of nature being out
there
and as a resource for us to use which is
one of the tenets of sustainability
um that we are allowed to go there and
use
the resources of the nature as long as
we leave enough for our future
generations to use that tenet is is
somewhat um
flawed um uh some some argue um
obviously now
um
in either case uh you know we seem to
need a major shift in our paradigm
because of our relationship with nature
uh whether sustainability is was wrong
from the beginning or it evolved into
what has now happened uh now
particularly in our industry the built
environment
uh which is a major user uh consumer of
materials and a major polluter of the
environment environment what would you
like to speak to that and tell us a bit
about how your projects and the work
that you are i know you are doing one of
which a couple of which you shared with
one of which
um the award-winning design
how do they
take its of different paths to the sort
of business as usual or the
sustainability as usual uh path of
extract use disposed model
i think you're
definitely a change of paradigm as as
you shared um it's definitely a new
time for designers to address the
sustainable questions just remember the
question from a different angle
um it's never anymore to use nature as
just a source of you know resources but
now we're looking at designs that really
are plugged in and integrated within
nature um so it's more symbiotic it's
more like
designed from
a broader vision
so we titled that from different sides
on my side um i mean the one percentage
here which is like the the reduction of
resources so fast it's like reduction of
material
reduction of energy on the production of
our build space
so it has to do with optimization of
processes
but not only that also we're looking at
other sources of materials that are more
sustainable so we're actually
implementing upcycling processes in the
fabrication of species and now we're
looking at
facade panels that can be
3d printed with plastic collected from
the oceans would try to give second life
to to to materials in a way that uh we
can extend their life and produce um
novel designs with it um so so i think
also we need to create um through our
production to our our designs a certain
culture
that things can be done differently i
think in industry typically things are
quite well established so it's very
difficult to disrupt the way that you
know traditional buildings are done
using traditional materials traditional
processes so i really think that we we
we have to say to start like showing a
different way to
to establish a relationship with nature
that affects different layers it's not
just only at the material level
definitely as architects i think we own
geometry so we need to actually use it
in a smarter way um there's a lot of
designs now bio-inspired using biomecry
so it's like many different like
new inputs that are changing the
landscape uh in which we design
and uh and i think it's just the
beginning i would say you can see that
trend uh from different sites not only
from the
construction industry so everyone wants
to
change the the way that they do things
every industry is actually looking at
sustainable processes so i think it's a
really good sign to to look at those
opportunities as designers to change the
way that we do things
fantastic thank you
a couple of a couple of questions on the
uh sort of some of the facts of your of
what what was presented from the
audience um like uh presume there's a
question whether
you actually had uh
foundations or pad proteins etc under
the
the container part of the
of the of the school building did you
did you have footage
where they just would spread the load
themselves and sit on the ground or
something
we did build a concrete pad on which the
foundation on which the containers were
sitting
exactly exactly okay thank you
um
obviously the
you your presentation and and the
answers to the to the couple of
questions i've asked you has generated a
lot of um a lot of interest a lot of
questions coming
um
particularly perhaps in response to the
uh the response that you guys gave on
the on the sustainability theme is um
the
um and what
some feel
to or to now replace that and which is
regenerative design
so
something for pearl i
i usually use
camping admiralty as as an example of a
successful regenerative thinking
uh beyond regenerative design or the the
umbrella under which genetic design
sits in some of my talks
you see the project addresses
regeneration at many levels of design
integration and you mentioned that
social integration that you beautifully
mentioned
and the environmental justice that we
that we spoke about earlier
nirmal's book
equal puncture so beautifully also
discusses these two
um and um
i think there is address that in
in flourish the book by
um sarah yorker and and michael pauling
both of these books are i highly
recommend to our to our audience at the
moment would you like to tell us a bit
about
the regenerative aspect
uh aspects of kampung admiralty about
you you've obviously touched on some of
it now you have a bit more time to to to
specifically talk about those aspects
about how the project
heals us more
than rather than pertussis
which was um
one of the descriptions of sustainable
design
i think we want to actually we always uh
strive to design the building as a
breathable building a building that
you know that allows
ventilation allows breeze to come
through allow a lot of natural light to
come through so i think being a a
breathable
building
brings
a lot of benefits yeah and um
in that way it's not just good for
the the users of the building but also
for the greenery that that we have in
the building
the other aspect is that in kampung
emerald we actually built up a
quite a robust uh blue and green
infrastructure so we're thinking of the
building system and the green system
yeah so the the blue is the blue is the
the storm water system that it's it's
managed it's it's uh make sure
that uh there's less runoff and there's
more uh
collection and reuse and recycle
uh of water and of course that that
integrates um
uh very closely with the landscape that
we are trying to create um together with
our consultant actually we
we actually layered the green into the
building so it is not just on one level
but i i think
we we realized there was so much benefit
of that that the biodiversity start to
happen
when the greenery was
was kind of interconnected across
vertically yeah
so that there was uh quite quite a lot
of uh
good good uh findings in in our
biodiversity survey yeah so this blue
and green infrastructure kind of
is the main um regenerative efforts
in the building of course the the
landscape
the tree species we were very
intentionally doing more edibles
yeah and and so it it does uh bring
benefits in terms of you know there is a
farm there is more edibles coming out of
it and
and people in the end enjoyed it because
they are living there they are taking
care of it so it's a little bit of a a
table a farm to table um kind of thing
happening yeah
great you you clearly mentioned um that
this was um it's obviously
a pioneering approach um to a mixed
development and he integrated to develop
a truly integrated uh development um
one of the things that i always wondered
was when you guys create these sort of
um
village development communities
whether it is here or in your dawson
project sort of the vertical
neighborhood sitting on top of one
another you obviously
reduce
uh and and
you need to reduce on trips from
going to to to shop or going to the park
or going to the medical center or
wherever it is that they want to go and
by virtue of that you reduce the demand
on roads and
and cars and and and everything else
you you must have some some some
feedback on on on how
uh you generally reduce the the the
energy use of of people getting from one
place to another throughout their days
or or or or you know weeks when they
live there and that how that obviously
reduces demand on on on on traffic and
everything else whether that is
intentional part part of possible work
or well that is like your byproduct of
the beautiful regenerative thinking that
you understand
actually that's that's uh definitely the
the idea we had for dawson
the skyview at dawson
that's why the the sky villagers was
was kind of of 11 story kind of
proportion we we think that with 11
story then you know it's just three or
four floors up or down
uh to access uh outdoor garden space
rather than take the lifts and go down
you know a 50-story building for example
yeah so i think in terms of of that it
helps with that the energy footprint uh
for force for high rise and high density
development that that we are doing here
in singapore yeah
true one of the things that i i read
about dawson feed feedback
during the use of the building was
as opposed to an otherwise
a similar
maybe perhaps
more conventional high-rise
development with the same profile of
users
more people in dawson tend to know their
neighbors
than they would you know in an otherwise
you know another conventional high-rise
day
is that something you have some numbers
on off the top of your head to share
with us
uh
not really numbers but i think that the
the the architecture helps to do that
because uh we were thinking about um uh
a kind of like because if you know your
neighbor very well right so in the sense
there is there is a social uh uh
structure there or you know you can use
the word social surveillance stuff
because you know you in your coming in
going out you or the sky garden you you
can see your neighbors
so i think that that helps
in the process of of uh making a
community or making friends with each
other and then form a community so we we
think that that would sustain it's
actually also community sustainability
if you like because you know if you are
not very rooted in in a community then
the tendency
would be to to move to a new place right
if if your life uh cycle changes or your
seasons of life changes yeah
so um i do have numbers but i think that
the the structure
uh creates that
the environment yeah
of getting
yeah
it's actually creating communities truly
placemaking and community making through
through design and to architecture
which you have
commendably done in in in more than one
of your projects of course um
one specific question about um
from the audience about um campaign
admiralty is
obviously the one-stop integrated
complex
whether you had any stringent
requirements
from different authorities perhaps moh
or just hdb alone as a as a client
um
were they specific uh challenges that
you that you face with those um
yeah actually that or there are um
well technical challenges from from
different
agencies of course there's one very
interesting one which is um
because
the land is limited and we had to
actually stack up the facilities and we
had to convince that the quieter nature
of those for example child care and
elder cash should be at the
upper floors
and uh it's not something
it is
but for the the agency
they actually prefer for example
chocolate to be at the lower floor
because of fire safety and so on yeah
but because we we put it at the
upper floor together with the garden
and the garden became a sort of like a
outdoor space
that
that is a refuge area where you know if
there's any emergency and
you can slowly evacuate
elderlies and children yeah by using all
these open open-air sky terraces yeah as
refuge area so i think it turned out to
be um
it it works you know
they they get a quieter environment and
it's it's ultimately also safe yeah
so this is one of those uh challenges
that we had yeah
excuse me yeah great thank you person a
number of questions are coming um from
the audience mainly anonymous attendees
um
about
your project uh obviously your approach
has
generated a
a lot of interest
um
one um
question um
thanking you for the presentation and of
course you're saying how inspiring
it is to work uh to see your work
uh the question is i wonder
can you share the process of designing
and implementing the school projects
that you presented what were some
difficulties that you might have
encountered and how did you overcome
them
you addressed some of them in your
presentation would you like to elaborate
on on some i'm sure you had more
problems than you shared with us
firstly i think the problems were
nothing unusual to any other project i
think every project has
its sense of problems and challenges
that you know to overcome right so
um and the fact that that we
we had taken this project upon ourselves
so we were prepared
that the problems would probably be a
little bit different than what we may
face another project and i think the key
issue really was the
uh
was the availability of the materials uh
one of the things i think we really like
in projects like like ours is to use
local materials and to impact materials
but they are not available in large
numbers of the right quality to be able
to build it fast enough so for us to get
wood and we were actually using recycled
wood that we could get we could we're
looking at recycled containers that we
could get but assembling all these
things together
at the right time on the site
maintaining them is actually not an easy
task
and that i think was was a critical
challenge that we faced and all saba is
also a region
with very long months and months um so
that would stop the work for a couple of
months so we couldn't build the school
fast enough as well
and i i have a feeling that if you would
have done probably a more conventional
building uh just using concrete and
brick blocks and bricks and block work
uh we could have probably found much
more labor which is used to it and we
could have probably delivered the school
much faster as well
um so i think that that's a key
challenge when we start working with
materials which are local where the
expertise is also limited and so is the
material just wanted uh presume um
one of the things that we keep talking
about
here about a paradigm shift about change
moving
from the sustainability curve to the
regenerative design curve it
change of course creates some some
issues some challenges i just wondered
whether that should not be one of the
tests that that we have for our next
projects that if um if you feel a little
bit more uncomfortable if you feel a
little bit more challenged um it
probably means that we're doing
something new or we're probably doing
something differently and and that could
be the test of um
that we should be pursuing
these sort of new ideas um where there
are there are not as many people and
who are
who are used to
uh building these things using these
materials and as the as the more the
challenges are
the more perhaps we are doing the right
thing
um in inviting and embracing change that
we that we that we need
i mean i think that's a that's a great
point and that's that's that's something
that we think about literally every day
right i think that the number of
challenges is face and our job really i
think i think my job as a leader of the
organization is really to try and reduce
these frictions that innovation and new
approaches bring right so how can we
reduce them and tackle
lesser and lesser of those right so the
fact that we could build such a school
in in malaysia in a very remote location
is quite possible if i was to try and do
this in singapore even though this might
be the correct way to do in terms of
sustainability and environment and
materiality just the regulations here
won't allow me to do this
so and i can't go and fight the system
to build the right kind of building here
so my kids like i was showing the
picture a
study in a school which is totally not
sustainable but the school teaches them
about sustainability but they do can't
observe them in that environment so we
as an organization and me as an
individual have taken an approach to say
how can we reduce that friction as much
as possible and only fight one fight at
a time as we move along because we just
want to have the
capacity and this probably leads to
maybe an example i want to share of of
some of the new work that we are doing
which is uh in the philippines where we
are building these uh net zero home
communities now
and we found that when we started going
and pitching it to to developers who are
our partners there that the level of
change that we were bringing in through
that project of building a net zero
building in terms of materials
construction technologies methodologies
financing
energy production water
sewage food production we had all these
things and then community aspects some
of the things that pearl talked about we
realized that those were just too many
for anybody to handle so we kind of
stripped it down of everything and we
said the only thing we would go in in
our first project to make sure that
innovation goes through is really
focused on two aspects which is energy
and net zero because of energy and the
financing based on energy because
there's a lot of impetus today in the
world in monetizing energy and there's
money flowing in there and we thought
that we will only focus on this aspect
in the first project that we are
building and as we prove our success in
it then we will push in the ideas of
better materials new construction
technologies water step by step and be
able to deliver our entire vision which
will probably i don't know take many
many years
beautiful thank you thank you for that
for that uh explanation uh carlos
as an engineer uh it's like you know
looking at your projects um
uh it's like a kid going to a candy shop
of course right
um as as a member of the jury when i saw
that project of course it's all my
sort of lights went on and
and the beautiful work that you and your
and your team are doing there is it
there is a question from the audience
and then there is a question from me uh
question from the audience um
and i must have i'm having a bit of a
problem reading these questions because
of some some typo of things that um
zeros are typed as o or or o's are typed
as zero and somehow it becomes a bit
cryptic but what i understand from the
question is something that
are you working on or is there a way to
make um
the sort of the nodes of of air mesh
even simpler
so that um
you know
it can be even more widely used and
produced by
by others
yeah that's a
it's a good question actually as we're
working now
on new version of the error system so
we're actually trying to solve this this
uh well this problems that we found when
we built the first version in
environments by the bay
so um i think um well the question is
more like how can we simplify i mean we
will simplify maybe the the way that we
can assemble the structure or even the
the assembly sequence so we are working
on that in a way that
it can become a product it can become
something that we can we can do
anywhere in singapore or in the world we
can send the parts and can be easily
assembled uh
the the complexity of the product is not
going to be reduced actually it's
enhanced we're actually talking more
interfaces with facades with other
members like are not just bart bar but
bar to ceiling facade so we are actually
making it more complex so we want to get
it instantly ready we want to get it
that ready to be used in commercial
architecture or
public buildings so we are actually
working now in a new version in which
we're using a higher grade steel
we want to get the approval from bca for
permanent construction by end of the
year so that will allow us to really
expand the
the use of the system and to test in
different conditions we think that um
we can target different functions and
skills uh from a domestic problem that
could be like extension of a house or
working in a very like intricate uh
location
to do something quite uh quite large and
using long span structures so that's why
we need to actually improve the
the
basically the the the way that the users
or the construction company are gonna
actually put it together because in the
end becomes a quite complex uh
ikea kind of uh structure right you need
to find the piece you need to bring the
right place you have to connect it
somehow so i think that's one of the big
things we're working on and we hope we
can solve that by end of the year
fantastic that's great another another
related question
is whether you're envisioning
reusing the material of the pavilion at
gardens by the bay after the exhibition
is that what is that going to be a
permanent permanent exhibition no
appendage feature there
well we for for this building in
particular we got the approval from bca
for three years engagement base so we
are actually fulfilling these three
years after that we'll be moving the
pavilion back to sutv and the plan is
actually to keep it in sctd as a
living
research piece so we want to keep it as
a way to test
new ideas new versions new connection
systems so also for
students and a new generation of
architects to to so how to get inspired
to really
see
one of the milestones we have achieved
in std that hopefully deceit many more
right in the next year so we want to
keep it there
for everyone to see over time but also
for us to keep testing new ideas on it
um the last question that i have um
um
for you uh carlos is um
uh the pda jury citation
um
i'm not sure whether it's confidential
or not that i i sort of wrote it
for a big chunk of it because that was
like
an engineer's dream as i as i said
it it recognizes as a cutting-edge
technology which firmly puts singapore
at the heart of
additive manufacturing one of your nodes
in fact looked like a human heart and
the pun was intended there
and in the case of working with 3d
printed stainless steel which reduces
material
you say by orders of magnitude you said
it's not more than 90 of the node is air
which is like free right um but you know
after this massive achievement and the
winning that you you deservedly did my
question would be to you like what is
what is you you shared some of it with
us but what is what is cooking in your
ssu tv lab now
um that you haven't shared with us
yeah i mean uh
actually
it's uh many things going on right now i
think we're getting a lot of abstraction
uh uh collaboration governments and with
industry
um we're looking at sustainable ways to
to impact
the build environment one of them we're
actually working really uh
you know
full-time on
it's on a developing uh components uh as
uh
from waste uh from discarded parts from
plastic from uh
from uh from basically turning waste
into functional parts either from
faucets uh or
facade panels so for us it's one layer
we're actually pushing because actually
synergistic with the earlier system we
think that we have the structure but
also we need to target other layers of
buildings we we want to explore also the
facade system so we can integrate both
synergistically and one more thing we're
pushing it strongly as well is
the challenge of 2030 food security uh
in our hdbs so we're working now with
hdb to
explore lightweight facades in a way
that we can use the facades that are not
open to the views to to grow veg and to
have like palm to table or the facade to
table
uh almost zero um carbon footprint there
so we're actually working with our
systems uh to to develop that um new
opportunity for singapore to grow food
in their hdb so which is quite exciting
too
great fantastic um
from one favorite to another one
of not only this project but presumes
general work
i was fortunate enough to be on the pda
jury in in 2018 as well when you turned
up
and
and you presented your shelter project
the sort of the the
motivation for that was that you turned
up and said that i'm gonna this is this
is a shelter for people who can't even
afford to live in
in in slums for some of us slums are the
lowest form of uh living
but this you you're actually catching
people who could not even be on that
ladder
step on the on the ladder then in 2020
you turned up and
your motivation was that i'm gonna uh
i've done a school for children who do
not even exist
i mean on officially did not exist on
any countries register as as you shared
with us
you know both super and honorable causes
of course um
uh but the question is like how do you
think of such worthy causes
and dreams
and then not only keep them at dream
level but go ahead and and and and
realize them
such determine in such determined manner
and what's next
and we have about eight seconds
officially on my time here but i'm told
that we could have a few minutes more
can we have a few minutes more
beautiful people here have beautiful
things to say
all right i appreciate that
and i'll probably take a few seconds
to
answer that question right i think
when i founded the uh when i founded
billion bricks um i actually went
uh to the boss of my old company where i
was working and i said i want to quit
and i want to start this company
and i want to do something which uh
which
which which is really like
some something that we want to speak
about but we don't really take action
right and the idea was really to focus
on housing
and my boss who is now my co-founder he
actually asked me that time
for soon a lot of work happens in slums
and you keep hearing about housing
things
but what do you think is the most
difficult thing to do
and would you have the ability to focus
on the most difficult part of problem to
be solved because that's no one is
solving
and that's how the idea emerged that
billion bricks wouldn't want to work in
slums but we would want to go for people
who are below the level of slums and
really find communities which are
extremely disadvantaged where even ngos
and nobody want even corporates don't
want to go and work on our sites right
so that's how the idea actually emerged
wasn't really my idea and i think the
motivation for me has primarily been the
fact that
i find that there are so many good
people in the world who support us who
believe in us who push us
and for some reason i don't know what
but we've been able to sustain ourselves
and continue
on that pathway right and and our
ambitions have just become
stronger and stronger and there's just
too many people in the world who want to
do the right thing and and we can
connect with them
thank you for that thank you for that
and
i would like to give you the last
uh say in the next couple of minutes
given the um
that the percentage of the
audience that we have or architects and
practicing architects is is quite high
so we would like to finish
uh with with you of course presume he's
also an architect
um
colors
are you an architect by training
yes
so three architects right
uh can you motivate us a little bit the
sort of work that waha waha
has been doing um and you're now known
worldwide um you're winning
international awards like camping
nightmares you won the building of the
year you know
ctv uh cancer hotel building in urban
habitat
um recently um
the the beautiful work that you've done
at the dubai expo for singapore um
singapore um pavilion
um
can you motivate us to to
try and
be like you a bit
do work of the type that you guys do
generating regenerative design
combining nature
with um
with natural environment with the built
environment the way you do
your two minutes starts now
i i
think um
you shouldn't need motivation i think we
are all motivated to to want to have a
better environment right because we we
know
the
once
we destroy it the the impact is very
hard to reverse yeah
and
i i think we should think of um
you know uh
creating food uh for example extending
uh green footprint a bit at a time yeah
and thinking and think of ways to
connect connect footprints so it doesn't
of course
we can do it on a grand scale but but
every building counts right because
each one can create
a footprint that's worth connecting
to to a bigger strategy yeah
so i i think
yeah
i i think it's
especially after the pandemic i think
it's it's um
everyone has got
this
greenery or bar feeling on on their
priority list already for example yeah
it's no longer needed to persuade them
because everyone knows that you know
clean air and clean environment
uh it should be on our priority yeah
thank you yeah the argument has been one
the deniers amongst us are very very few
you're absolutely right work
distinguishes what differentiates us
between
or not between those who know and who do
not know but between those who do and do
not do
it's too bad and it's about acting and
someone said that that the
delayers are the new deniers now those
who know but do not do are uh in the
issue of the environment um on that note
and with five minutes and 11 seconds um
overrun
my apologies to our
drmc juliana and i uh thank you the
three of you for the for the beautiful
work that you do and pass you to
juliana thank you
thank you so much thank you thank you so
much once again dr rezway for keeping
time so accurately and for our
recipients for sharing your experience
with our audience to our audience we'll
also appreciate it if you could help us
to complete a short survey for this
webinar to help us to improve on our
future programs
for boa and sia members a gentle
reminder for you to fill in the survey
form with your relevant details to
qualify for the cpd points
there will be a special giveaway where
you can receive an exclusive hard copy
of the pda 2020 publication when you
share your greatest takeaway from the
webinar so right now please do scan the
qr code for the survey form and if you
would like to find out more about the
various upcoming programs the national
design center has lined up do also scan
the qr code that you see on the screen
and with that we will be ending the
session for today thank you once again
to all of our speakers and to all of you
for spending your friday afternoon with
us we certainly look forward to seeing
you at our future events have a good
evening ahead and goodbye